it's been nearly a month since imali saw
her son
she waits for news outside the military
tribunal where ali is among dozens of
men
facing trial on terrorism charges
[Applause]
those charges can carry the death
penalty and are seen as an escalation in
the ongoing conflict between the state
and the people
they're accusing our sons of being
terrorists they are the terrorists
they stole the people's money they are
responsible for the explosion at the
beirut port
our children are nationalists not them
the defendants are alleged to have
thrown molotov cocktails at security
forces
and burned down a municipality building
during protests in the northern city of
tripoli
last month the demonstrations were held
to demand
government compensation during a strict
coronavirus lockdown that worsened
living conditions
for the poor one protester was shot in
the back during the unrest
his family and activists want to know
why no
charges have been brought against those
responsible for killing him
omar taiba who was martyred was killed
by this man they know who fired the shot
and they are not telling us lawyers have
criticized the use of a military court
to try the defendants
and say they have been obstructed from
seeing them they also
say the young men were interrogated
without lawyers being present
and described the charges as unlawful
arbitrary
and a form of oppression this escalation
has three reasons for us first is to put
a stigma
on the protesters mainly in tripoli that
they are terrorists
second is to put the fear factor
to the protesters not to hit the streets
again and third
is like to put the pressure on the
investigation judge not to release the
detainees
human rights groups say terrorism
charges should be used for serious
political crimes and not
acts of public disorder repression has
increased
in lebanon since a nationwide protest
movement began more than a year ago
security forces have been accused of
using excessive and
unlawful force against the demonstrators
lengthy pre-trial detentions
prosecutions with limited rights to
appeal
interrogations without the presence of a
lawyer and beatings have all been
documented
warnings that free speech and assembly
are at risk
are not new for many the dwindling
numbers of those who continue to speak
out
is a testament of that reality senator
al-jazeera
beirut